first up a major development tonight in
the controversy over the security
clearance for the president's son-in-law
who is also one of his top advisors
chief White House correspondent John
Roberts joins me here in the North Lawn
with the latest information about access
for Jared Kushner correct good evening
to you as you know the chief of staff
John Kelly changed the rules regarding
security clearances in the wake of the
recent Rob Porter scandal that meant
that last Friday which was a
self-imposed deadline by Kelly a number
of White House staffers had their
security clearances reduced
including Jared Kushner the
investigation into his security
clearance still not completed first
son-in-law Jared Kushner had his
clearance downgraded from interim top
secret to interim secret this means that
while Kushner can still view some
classified information he can no longer
see the most sensitive items like the
president's Daily Brief asked about the
downgrade late this afternoon President
Trump wouldn't answer last week the
president said he would leave it to his
chief of staff to decide what to do
about Kushner security clearance so
that'll be up to general Kelly a general
Kelly respects Jared a lot and general
Kelly will make that call I won't make
that call the downgrade is not expected
to affect the work that Kushner is doing
at the White House on policy and the
Middle East peace process in a statement
a spokesperson for Kushner telling Fox
News mr. Kushner has done more than what
is expected of him in this process those
involved in the process again have
confirmed that there are dozens of
people at mr. Kushner's level whose
process is delayed no concerns were
raised about mr. cush news application
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
informed the White House three weeks ago
that there were still a number of items
in Kushner's file that required further
investigation it is not known when that
process will be completed or whether
Kushner will receive his full security
clearance
the Department of Justice did weigh in
today on president Trump's request to
ban so-called bump stocks used last
October by the Las Vegas shooter
attorney general Jeff Sessions saying he
believes it could be done without going
through Congress but our top people in
the Department of Justice will have
believed for some time that we can
through regulatory process not allow the
bump stock to convert a weapon from
semi-automatic to fully automatic on the
broader issue of gun safety and school
shootings the White House today said it
will have some policy proposals to
announce later this week one question
will the president make good on his
pledge to raise the minimum age to buy a
rifle or shotgun to 21 from 18 to do it
he'd have to go up against the NRA which
is striving Lee opposed to the idea the
president said yesterday if they're not
always with you sometimes you got to
fight them is he willing to take on the
NRA the president still supports raising
the age limit to 21 for the purchase of
certain firearms were meeting with
bipartisan members of Congress tomorrow
we expect that to be a topic of
discussion
he knows that everybody doesn't
necessarily agree and some other news at
the White House that happened today
President Trump is Brett pointed out
named his 2020 campaign manager Brad
parse scale he will also liaised with
all of the congressional races between
now and November trying to hold on to
the House and the Senate in the November
elections the midterm elections the
president also announcing today that he
cut a deal for two new Air Force one
aircraft with Boeing it'll be a 3.9
billion dollar deal the president brett
says he's saving 1.4 billion dollars off
the initial cost estimate at more than
five billion dollars he likes to talk
about that's saving the money on those
those deals he does you know if the art
of the deal but he bought a couple of
airframes that were already to existence
so that saved a little bit of money
alright John thank you thanks